david what are the best arguments
against
democracy isn't it just perfect
as we eclipse the trump era
that the best argument against democracy
is donald trump and and what i mean by
that is this is the platonic argument
against democracy
left to the masses the masses often make
stupid decisions left to demand to the
masses
lots of ignorant people get to decide
this i'm not coming up with this and i'm
not saying this is my
perspective or that i want to get rid of
democracy but
look at plato's republic plato viewed
democracy this
takes me back to my days in philosophy
101.
plato viewed democracy sort of like a
interme a liminal look that one up a
liminal
phase between oligarchy and tyranny
and plato and i'm sort of summarizing
from memory here
to plato democracy was probably
too fond of freedom
and equality and indulging people who
have no business
influencing how a culture society
economy or country
should be run and that there are costs
to that
there is no way in full democracy or we
don't really even have that in the
united states but in something point
pretending to be full democracy
to ensure that we have competent
administrators
and people in power that's a risk of
democracy
um there is not enough in most
democracies to really crack
down on the elites and those in power
uh who are squeezing the average
people we've seen that in american
democracy
and the idea of plato again i'm
summarizing was that
in democracy eventually things point to
people falling for some kind of
strong man that they believe will make
things better
but points us in the direction of
tyranny and of course
that's exactly what we saw under donald
trump
so the the downsides of democracy are
the last four years and it should
really be you know for for for many
people learning about this stuff
it was here was plato's idea
and it's sort of like a thought
experiment i guess although there are
there are
historical examples of it happening we
have one now in the united states we've
seen the downsides of democracy which is
that ignorant people
put an authoritarian buffoon in power
and he starts moving us in the direction
of authoritarianism he was a wannabe
dictator now from a practical standpoint
aside from democracy is good versus bad
one of the flaws uh of
of a of a democracy is that particularly
for really large countries
it's tough to come up with a cohesive
strategic direction for the country
because you have the constant second
guessing and flip-flopping of power
and this is why when we talk about well
trump says he had to do executive orders
to undo the bad things obama did even
though executive orders were bad under
obama
trump had no choice and now biden has to
do executive orders to undo the terrible
things that
donald trump did and there's this
constant looming
uh reversal of what is done
because of the system we have and
because there's always some election
looming i know this is crazy but
the members of congress in about six
months have to start campaigning for
re-election for 2022
they get two-year terms and so that that
is always there
so a lot of this now goes beyond the
idea of democracy
but when you have a sys when you have a
world in which
many of the problems we're trying to
solve are more than two-year projects
or they're more than four-year projects
but we have
every member of congress up for
re-election every two years
and every president up for re-election
or a presidential election every four
years
senators every six uh you're not really
creating circumstances
that uh benefit the longer term
issues that we as a as a society as as
humans need to deal with so
i am not anti-democracy but there are
arguments
against democracy and the best ones all
come
from what we saw over the last four
years